すいません
非常に大人気のない動画になっております
この動画に関してはもう
UUMの許可もマネージャーの許可も取っ
ておりません完全に
独断も自分の意思でこの動画を出したいと
思って動画を
撮ってます
ひょっとしたら
ご迷惑をおかけする
関係者の方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
が
申し訳ございません
ここ1年
の
活動
ここ1年のはじめしゃちょーの活動を通し
て思っていたことそして今後どうなるかを
ちょっと皆様にお話ししたいと思います
えーまず今年1年の総評としましてまあ
まずちょっと早いですけどももう12月だ
からいいでしょう今年1年はじめしゃ
ちょー活動を
色々させていただきましたまあ純粋に感想
だけ言うと
非常に
悔やまれる1年でしたはい
非常に悔やまれる1年でしたもうその一言
に僕は尽きるかなと思ってますはじめしゃ
ちょー忙しい
僕からも忙しいってよく
言ってますはい
正直に言いましょう
結構忙しいです忙しいことですごい
ありがたいことだと思うんですよ誰かに
必要にされたり初めて社長というものが
必要だったりこうね少なくとも何か影響力
があって必要とされてそして僕のしたい
ことがあってこういろんな理由で忙しい
ことってあると思うんですけどもまあ今年
1年バーっと見返してみるとあの
忙しいの理由がほとんど僕の
メインチャンネルの動画
案件とか抜いてね本当に僕がやりたいと
思っているメインチャンネルの動画以外の
ことですほぼ
ほぼそうどういうことが
多かったかっていうともちろん
案件の動画撮影企業さんとのタイアップの
動画だったり
テレビの収録です
テレビの収録とか別のチャンネルの撮影と
かもありましたしCMの撮影とかなんか
本当色んな方とかいろんな場所に必要とさ
れるのがとてもありがたくて忙しかったん
ですけれども
あまりにそこが忙しすぎて
正直今年は12
[音楽]
ヶ月1年でやりますけども
8月だけ
8月だけでした
満足に動画が撮れたのはそれ以外の月は
正直メインチャンネルに
力を注ぐことができずに
他のお仕事だったり
他のチャンネルだったりテレビだったり
いろんなことで
僕のはじめしゃちょーという人間の
力をそっちの方法に使っていました
企業案件とかテレビの収録とかCM撮影と
か
すごい
嬉しいんですよテレビのCMなんですそう
そう来ないですから
めっちゃ嬉しいしテレビとかも嬉しいです
それだけ
色んな人に認められて
るっていうことだなと思って僕は嬉しく
思ってます企業案件もそう案件なんて」
って思われる方いらっしゃるかもしれませ
んけども
企業さんとこうタイアップとか企業案件
じゃないとできなかった企画今年も山ほど
ありましたやりたくない仕事は1つも
なかったです
全部自分の中でやりたいと思ってあ必要と
されてるんだったら受けたい期待にお答え
したいと思って
全部始め社長が今年でやらせていただいた
ものは全て
自分の意思で受けさせていただいて
本当に貴重な経験もできたしすごい勉強に
なったし本当にどれ一つ自分の中ではダメ
なものはなかったって言えますが
言えるんですけど
優先順位が違ったなっていうのが今年の1
番の
悔やまれる部分
メインチャンネル
全然出せてないんですよあと時間もかけれ
てないそこに
脳みそも使えてないとってもありがたい
悩みですしなんだそれって思われるかも
しれないですけども
メインチャンネル以外のお仕事が本当に
今年はたくさんいただきましてそれで
忙しい1年でしたその結果
メインチャンネルに全く耳が入らなかった
ですでなんでこれが起きたかっていうと
もうね
本当にあのUUMが悪いわけではないん
ですよ
UUMに関しては本当に
感謝してますもちろん案件の掃除を
やり取りとかも全部してもらったりテレビ
の収録とかもずっと付き添っていただいて
何か僕に不自由がないかとか全部サポート
していただいたりありとあらゆる場面で
本当にサポートしていただいててとっても
ありがたい
ですただ
スケジュールがスケジュールがちょっと
無茶があったかなって思う瞬間はなんとか
ありましたでもねそれも多分ねもううーむ
さんとかマネージャーさんがコントロール
できるようなもんじゃない気がしてて
テレビの収録とかって僕に合わせられる
もんじゃないわけじゃないですかいろんな
演者さんとか共演者さんとかがいて
スタジオを抑えてそこに時間を合わせて
みんなに行くから僕1人のスケジュールで
合わせられないという僕が次の日
例えば24時間何かしてるとしても前日に
テレビの所属があったらテレビの収録を
やんなきゃいけないし運は悪くないです
むしろ
僕からするといつも言ってくれる
マネージャーさんたちはすごい優しいし
好きなんですけど
だからこそ
断りづらいのかもしれないてか断りたく
ないんですよね
案件とか楽しいですし
企業さんとしかできないこともちろんある
しテレビもすごいありがたいです
必要とされていますとっても嬉しいです
人柄必要とされてることって嬉しくない
ですかなんかこれ
ずっと悩んでて
悩んでて母ちゃんにも相談したんですよ
他の仕事が多くて
自分のメインチャンネル
自分のしたいことができないって
でそしたら
あんた平安主義者だからねってなんか
あんた平和すぎじゃでとりあえず揉め事を
起こしたくないとか
誰かが困るの見たくないからとりあえず
イエスって言っちゃう癖があって自分のし
たいことを後回しにして
だから
親に何かそういう風に育てちゃった私が
悪いのかなみたいなことを言ってて
その通りです本当に自分のしたいことを
正直にマネージャーさんとか
UUMに
言えなくてどんどん後回しになって結局
取れてない
というのが今年の
感想ですはい
素直に言うと
全くメインチャンネルの動画に
集中できてませんでしたし
企画ネタを考える時間もなく思ったように
うまくいかなかった1年だったなって思い
ましたこれも本当に
僕が悪いです正直自業自得です
嫌なことはやって言うべきだったしでも
なー
uumaさんも会社なんですよUUMさん
も事務所で会社でやっぱり
儲けが出ないとお金にならないと
成り立たないわけであって難しいよね俺が
案件とかさお仕事を全部断るとひょっとし
たら
会社にすごい迷惑をかけたりしてるのかも
しれないっていう勝手に僕は一人で俺が
やんなきゃっていう責任感はありました
俺優しいんですよはい親も
言ってたんで多分そうだと思います
優しいんです
そうするタイプなんです
多分だから
YouTuberになったんだと思う1人
で動画撮ってたら誰のことも考えなくて
いいし自分のしたいこと好きなことできる
から俺はこの仕事を選んだんですけど
気づいたら周りに人が増えて仲間が増えて
いろんな中のいいYouTuberとかも
増えてそんな大切な人たちに頼みごとさ
れると
自分のしたいことを
後回しにしてでも
やってしまう
そんな
クソみたいな人間です
もったいない
もうちょっと
今年の反省はもっと
自分の思いとが考えを
ちゃんと周りの人に言えばよかったなと
思うしでも
自分の中で結構そう言ってて自分の中で何
が一番幸せかっていうと動画撮ってる時
って結構いろんなとこで言ってるしなんと
なく心のどこかでマネージャーさんとか
事務所の人とかにそこ伝わってるのかなっ
て思ってたんですけどもそこのこう
意思疎通ができてなかったり
コミュニケーション不足だったりしたのか
なと
思ってます
インフルエンサー
芸能人タレントとしてはもう大成功の1年
だったと思いますけど動画クリエイターと
しては
僕は
満足の一手いない1年だったなと思います
ごめんこの動画をごめんなさい勝手に出し
ちゃって多分
事務所に言うと1回ストップかけられそう
なので勢いで撮ってますけども1個だけ
勘違いしないで欲しいのは今年受けてきた
案件これからはもう受ける案件お仕事全て
自分がいいと思って受けてるやつですただ
もちろん今後も案件だったりテレビとか
CMとかそういうのあのタイミングがあれ
ば今後もいただけるようだったりやりたい
んですけども1個だけ
僕からのたった1つだけの願いは
メインチャンネルを取る時間
考えられる時間動画を作れる時間それだけ
が欲しいそれだけが
僕の
思いというかリクエストですそれはですね
もうずっと思ってたし多分マネージャー
さんたちも薄々感づいてはいたと思うん
ですけどさっきちゃんと思ってることを
しっかり話して改善していただけるという
形にはなってますもちろんUUMさんも
よきと思ってやってくれてたからなって
いいでしょ
普通に考えていいことなんですよお仕事
たくさんあるってすごいいいことですただ
俺はテレビ進出とかも
興味ないしなんかこれ以上有名になりたい
とかもないしめっちゃお仕事したいとか
そういうのもないです動画を作るのが
楽しくて好きでやってるのでそれが続けれ
ばいいっていう思いだけですそれだけそれ
が今年はかなわなかったのでちょっと
悔しい1年になりましたし土属させて
いただいておりますUUMにもこの思いは
伝えました本当に正直つい
前まではもうどうは帰っても動画を
考える時間取る時間もないぐらいの
スケジュールで
動いていたので改善されることを
願ってますだからひょっとしたら今後は
頼まれると断れないような性格までも
把握してくれてるとは思っているのでな
それぐらいすごいしんないと高いんで
ちょっと大丈夫だと思うんですけどもただ
やっぱりUUMを事務所で会社だし
いろんなお仕事しないと成り立たないので
もし仮にですよもし仮にもし仮に変わらず
にあの
メインチャンネルが取れないような状況が
続くことがあれば
僕はおそらく迷いなくUUMをやめると
思いますだってお互いにメリットないです
し多分
大丈夫だと思うしねなんか突然俺がさ
UUMやめますバーンってなってもさ何
みたいな「UUMってそんな悪い会社なの
とかなるのも嫌だしなんか色んな噂される
のも嫌なんで
先に言っておくともしよもし仮にはじめ
しゃちょーが運を辞めたら初め社長と
ウームが
合わなくなった瞬間だと思ってください
もうそれだけいい事務所よ
本当にいろんなこと手伝ってもらってるし
いい人がいっぱいで
俺はUUM好きなんですけど
好きが故に自分のしたいことを後回しにし
ちゃってるっていう本当にそれだけはい
これあのUUMに確認とかも出してなく
動画出してるんで本当に本心で話してます
もしやめたら
UUMが求めるクリエイターに
僕がねなかったというそれだけの話なので
やめてもそんなに落ち込まないでください
まあそうならないことを僕も祈ってますし
仲良くできたらいいなと思ってます
本当にでもね何かを
してないといけないというか僕も時間が
限られてるんで受けたい仕事とか結構断っ
てるんですよUUMとはちゃんとお話しし
たので今後はおそらく
僕のメインチャンネルの撮影を第1優先で
してくれると思いますなんかねえ
優しい
子に育ててくれた母ちゃんのせよもっと
わがままで無理無理そんなの嫌ですとか
そういう人間だったらこうはなってないの
かなとか思いつつ平和が一番じゃないです
か何事もだから
僕が我慢すればいいんだろうなっていう
感じでいたんですけどすいませんどうして
も
メインチャンネルのはじめしゃちょーの
チャンネルのことに関してだけは
引き下がれなかったです
すいませんこんな裏話をしてただそういう
感じの1年だったし教育はきっと
改善されてると思います
案件とかお仕事が似合ってわけじゃない
から
自分でちゃんといいですねそれって言って
受けてるのでとか皆さんほんと勘違いし
ないでいただけると嬉しいですなんせ
メインチャンネルが出したい出したかった
1年でしたし今日以降そして
来年からはちょっとYouTube頑張り
たいなって思ってます
言っちまったなぁ大丈夫でしょ
誰も悪いって言ってないもんほんと誰も
悪くないですね俺が俺が
甘かったっていう話です
じゃあな
だから
頑張ります